rihanna claps back at a heckler who
calls her out for being fashionably late
and it's
legendary whatever i do it's gonna be
confident on tuesday riri who is
expecting her first kiddo with boyfriend
asap rocky was a little bit tardy to the
dior show at paris fashion week and when
one attendee decided to call out the
singer for being late rihanna shut that
ish down with the perfect two-word
response
let's play that back one more time shall
we
and that's how you dropped the mic
people it was fun but riri's clapback
wasn't the only iconic moment of the
night just check out her ensemble that's
the 34 year old mama to be putting her
baby bump on full display in a sheer
black dress with black lingerie a
leather cape and matching knee-high
leather boots which she accessorized
with silver jewelry including a choker
and layered chain necklaces of course
this is just the latest in a string of
bold pregnancy looks for riri i'm trying
to enjoy it as much as i could and
fashion is one of my favorite things so
you know redefining what it means to
even be
pregnant and maternal you know it always
it it can get uncomfortable at times so
you know you can dress the part and
pretend she rocked this body-hugging
coral number to the off-white show in
paris and showed off her baby bump in a
crop top at the gucci show in milan last
week rihanna first revealed she was
expecting back in january it's turning
out great so far so good and shared this
snap of her growing bump on instagram a
few days later i couldn't tell you how
happy i am a source at the time told et
that rihanna and asap rocky enjoyed
keeping their pregnancy a secret for as
long as they could but they're thrilled
to be able to share the news with their
fans i'm just excited for what i don't
know yet you know everything is new to
me so
you know i'm excited and last month the
fenty beauty founder opened up to e.t
about how she's feeling leading up to
motherhood what are you enjoying most
about this journey uh donuts so far
but besides the obvious you know
i'm looking forward to it you know this
is it's all an exciting journey so far
i'm just taking it as it comes every
week it's something new
and i'm just taking it i'm enjoying it
do you think this stage in your life is
going to inspire new music yes you're
still going to get music from me maybe a
lullaby i can see you and asap dropping
demos in the studio
oh my goodness not a lullaby my fans
would kill me they waited this long for
a lullaby letting us sleep with this
music they're like we are grown
[Music]